on en vient la crise diplomatique entre
paris et alger après la réduction des
visas et les propos d' emmanuel macron
sur la légitimité historique d'étonnant
au pouvoir en algérie oui en réaction
alger a décidé de fermer hier son espace
aérien aux avions militaires de
l'opération marque anne pour plus de
précision va tout de suite retrouvé
notre correspondant au maghreb basse m
shelly
[Musique]
bonjour bassem
bonjour magali et bonjour olivier
bonjour à vous alors alger ce matin
n'est pas content après les propos d'
emmanuel macron dans le journal le monde
effectivement malgré l'impression que le
ciel s'assombrit de plus en plus entre
alger et paris une crise diplomatique
entre les deux rives ça va commencer
déjà il ya quelques temps il ya quand
même quelques mois concernant cette
question de la mémoire cher à l'algérie
et puis il ya eu cette déclaration de
l'état santé concernant les visas
délivrés aux pays du maghreb ou paris
qui avait déclaré baissé de - 50 % les
visas pour les algériens et les
marocains qui voudraient venir en france
est de -30 % pour les tunisiens une
annonce qui avait fait plutôt polémique
au maghreb les différents chefs d'état
ainsi que le roi du maroc avait exprimé
leur incompréhension face à cette
décision de paris et puis hier on a vu
que les tensions étaient montés à d'un
cran paris qui avait alger qui avait
annoncé fermé son espace aérien aux
avions militaires français qui devront
maintenant nous pourrons plus survoler
le territoire algérien
au calme en a qui étaient monnaie
courante dans le cadre de l'opération
barkan c'est une décision maguèye qui
intervient dans un contexte de tension
bien palpable entre paris et alger de
paris sg qui a rappelé pour
consultations son ambassadeur à paris
excellent son rejet catégorique des
déclarations attribuées à emmanuel
macron alger qui évoque mâcon pardon qui
évoque un système politico militaire au
pouvoir alger cite des propos qui n'ont
pas été démentis ceux d'emmanuel macron
qui ont été retranscrits par nos
confrères du journal le monde samedi le
quotidien qui relate une rencontre entre
le chef de l'état est un groupe de
jeunes issus des algériens qui avaient
combattu pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale selon le même quotidien le
monde le chef de l'état avait déclaré
qu' après l'indépendance algérienne
l'algérie s'est construite sur une rente
mémorielle entretenu par un système
politico militaire emmanuel macron qui
évoquait une histoire officielle
totalement réécrit par alger qui ne
s'appuient pas sur des vérités mais sur
un deal trouve qui repose sur la haine
de la france il n'en fallait pas moins
pour mettre le feu aux poudres est pour
attiser la colère d'alger alger qui est
a déclaré qu emmanuel m'a conté preuve
d'ingérence dans les affaires
algériens la tension est très palpable
entre ces deux rives l'acquis son
mémorielle très importante pour les
algériens même si tout le monde sait
qu'en 2020 les deux pays avaient confiés
à des chercheurs des deux rives un
travail de mémoire sur une optique de
réconciliation entre la france et
l'algérie pour le moment les tensions
restent palpables une crise diplomatique
qui gonfle entre alger et paris alors
qu'il agirait paris était censé bientôt
conjointement commémorer les 60 ans de
la fin de la guerre d'algérie
merci beaucoup bassin pour toutes ces
précisions ben hassen chébili en direct
de tunis pour rt france